they don't get the radicalism we're up
against you know I actually had the
privilege of asking a question of Karen
bass here in bass is a California
congressman
Karen bass is the head of the
Congressional Black Caucus and Karen
bass is being strongly considered to be
Joe Biden's running mate now no one's
asking her tough questions obviously so
I was offered the opportunity by Alex
Michaelson who's an anchor at Fox in LA
to come on and ask Karen bass any
question I wanted so I asked her a
question about her troubling support for
Marxists she works very closely with and
supports the black lives matter movement
which we've talked about on this show
the leaders of BLM refer to themselves
as trained Marxists one of them took a
photo with the Communist dictator of
Venezuela and kicked congresswoman bass
herself has expressed support for Fidel
Castro praised Fidel Castro when he died
so my question to her with that context
was very simple I said I said
representative bass are you willing to
disavow Marxists and if you are assuming
that you are why do you continue to
support self-described Marxists here's
her answer that's very interesting
because I've known black lives matter
individuals for quite a while and I have
never known of black lives matter to be
a Marxist organization you know one of
the challenges with organizing today
that's very different when I was coming
up is that we did have more solid
organizations whereas now you can have
people who are affiliated with a lot of
different different groups so that's a
black lives matter chapter that I'm
surely not aware of
oh she's surely not aware of that black
lives matter chapter except it's not a
chapter it's the national leadership and
I have proof that she is aware of them
here is patrisse cullors
one of the cofounders of black lives
matter describing both she and we're
describing herself and her co-founder
Alicia Garza as trained Marxists I think
that the criticism is helpful and
I also think that it might I think of a
lot of things the first thing I think is
that we actually do have an ideological
frame myself analicia in particular
trained organizers we are trained
Marxists we are super versed on sort of
ideological theories of course we know
they're versed on this ideological
theory of Marxism anybody who reads the
about Us section of the website of BLM
would would know that I mean they use
the word comrades a lot they want to
abolish the police and they want to
abolish the quote Western prescribed
nuclear families so it's very strange to
me that Karen bass who works with BLM
wouldn't know the national leaders and
wouldn't have heard this very now viral
clip of them openly describing
themselves as trained Marxists so I did
like two seconds of googling and I found
out wait a second Karen bass actually
does know them there's a photo of Karen
bass speaking with patrisse cullors in
Congress and then congresswoman bass
tweets out afterward thank you to Alicia
Garza and Patrice colores for joining
the black caucus for a forum on police
brutality this morning Congress needs to
act so not only did she have this
conversation in Congress on the record
she later tweeted about it so so this
idea that she doesn't know them is a
flat-out lie
after she lied LX Michaelson the anchor
of the program pushed her on the
question of her support for Fidel Castro
and she ducked that one too if I had to
do it over again I probably would have
deleted that if it offended people but
again promoting the relations between
our two countries I would never do that
over again she would probably not use
that phrase if it offended people if it
offended people this is a non-apology
apology this is sorry I'm not sorry she
doesn't regret supporting this Fidel
Castro's evil ideology she doesn't
regret supporting his brutality she
regrets it
if it offends people my question was
will you disavow Marxism she wouldn't
she didn't she denied the premise and
she lied then she deflected and she
never did
why didn't she because she's an of
course she's not willing to disavow
Marxism compare this to the way that
Trump is treated Trump every single day
still disavowed white supremacy because
I disavow
yeah but do you really disavow it again
okay i disavow white supremacy it's
terrible
remember charlottesville where he
allegedly called white supremacists and
neo-nazis very fine people remember in
the exact same breath when you talked
about how they were fine people on both
sides of the monument issue he said I'm
not talking about the neo-nazis and the
white supremacists who should be
condemned totally remember how multiple
multiple times during the campaign this
is why won't you condemn David Duke he
says I condemn David Duke I don't know
David Duke sure I condemn my disavow
doesn't matter it's never enough and yet
this woman seriously being considered
for Joe Biden's running mate he's asked
a simple question do you disavow Marxism
after all the support you've shown for
it over the years repeatedly and
continually she refuses to do
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description